You are listening to
radiolab radio from W N y.
S. E. N. P. R.
Hello David. Yes. Hello. This
is pat. Oh, hi pat. All right,
let's begin with this story from our
producer Pat Walters. Pat, go ahead. Okay.
So I heard this one from this guy
named David, Ms. David bus to ss.
He's a psychology professor at
the University of Texas at Austin.
And this particular story, it comes
from a book that David wrote. Um,
could you just, just tell me, uh,
the little story that you begin
your book with? Okay. Yes. Um,
this is one of the things that, uh,
this was one of the things that sparked
my interest in the topic of murder.
The whole thing happened several
years ago. I had a very good friend,
another professor at the university,
and I used to socialize
with him and his wife.
And one evening they were throwing
a party and invited me over.
And so when I went to the party,
a party was already in full swing.
And I got there, uh, walked
in and asked his wife, uh,
where this friend of mine was. And, uh,
she got a disgusted look on her face
and said that he was up in the bedroom.
And so I went up to the bedroom
to find them. And he was in a,
in a rage, in a rage.
How, like you walk into the room,
what do you find? Well, he's
started, he started fuming that
his wife had, had dissed him.
And what did she do? Uh,
she expressed disapproval about his, uh,
clothing choices. She made
fun of his shirt or something,
but did it in publicly in front of
her friends. So it was a kind of,
he felt publicly humiliated.
And while David's sitting in
the bedroom with this friend,
the guy looks up at him and he
says, I'm going to kill her.
How did he say it? Like quietly
or like through his teeth,
you know, I'm going to kill her.
David had always known this
guy to be pretty mild mannered,
but he,
it is a, uh, a large,
very strong man, um,
with a black belt in karate.
I knew what he was capable of.
And so I suggested that we go out for a
walk and I basically spent the next half
hour walking around with
him, trying to cool him off.
But eventually he did.
He just calmed down. Hmm.
And did you go back to the party then
and like continue dinner partying for
awhile?
Yeah, I did. Yes. And he did too.
And then he seemed fine when I said
goodbye to him, it seemed common.
I left and went home and then it was
several hours later in the middle of the
night that I got the call
and it was his friend
and he says, can I come over
and sleep on your couch?
Uh, if I don't leave my house
right now, I'm going to kill her.
He was in this, um, a state of fury,
he said, and um, and
instead of hitting his wife,
he smashed his fist into the bathroom
mirror and then realized that he had to
leave the house or he was
gonna do damage to her.
And so he says that in, you're
like, okay, yes, come over now.
Like, yeah, exactly.
Meanwhile, later that night
and the other side of town,
his wife, um, went into hiding,
literally disappeared for six months
and didn't tell anyone where she was
because she was terrified
that he was going to kill her.
This story made us
wonder, is David's friend,
is he unusual or does everybody at some
point have something dark in them that
just tip toes out? Just
from time to time? Yeah.
This is Radiolab and today we're
going to get back so to speak.
We've done a good show. This is
the bad show. So you asked like,
why do people do bad things
actually mean to be bad anyways?
Like how do you tell the real baddies
from the rest of us? That's time our,
I'm Jad have them. Ron,
I'm up. [inaudible] this
is Radiolab, the bad show.
[inaudible]
back to bed. Okay. Uh, so what happened
to David that night with his friend,
got him really curious about murder
and badness and all these things we're
thinking about.
But it wasn't until a few years later
that he learned something that really put
what happened that night in the
context. The next, at this point,
David moved on to a new university and
he's teaching an introductory psychology
class
and I devoted one class session to the
topic of homicide and why people kill.
And I designed a little, um,
questionnaire where I simply
asked the students, you know,
have you ever thought about killing
someone? And they would circle yes or no.
Then he left some space at the bottom
for them to elaborate if they said yes,
and, you know, the class ended.
And I went back to my office and I just
sat at my desk and I started reading
these and I was just astonished
to find page after page of
yeses and not just yeses,
but these very vivid descriptions about
who they would kill, where they
do it, when the precise method,
how many of them went
into that kind of detail?
Uh, I would say 75 or 80%. Wow. Um,
and are you a little bit like
horrified? Like, oh my God,
my students are murderer. All
right. Well, I horrified as I was,
I was pretty stunned.
And so I expanded the sample where we
asked about 5,000 people all over the
world. Singapore Heru the UK.
That same question, have
you ever thought about that
killing someone?
And 91% of the men said
yes and 84% of the women,
yes. I've thought about killing someone.
Yes.
If any sizable fraction actually
acted on their homicidal fantasies,
the streets would be running, running red.
Yeah. But that's just
a, those are fantasies.
And some of them actually
seem like, well, here's one,
something more than just fantasies from
a woman. Sure. Okay. This
is a 20 year old female. Uh,
we ask, who did you think about
killing? And she said, my ex boyfriend,
um, we lived together for a couple
of months. He was very aggressive.
He started calling me a whore and
told me he didn't love me anymore.
So I broke up with him. Then a few
months later he started calling me,
trying to get back together,
but I didn't want to.
He said that if I ever had a
relationship with another man,
he was going to send the videos of
us having sex to all the people in my
university. The thing is that
I do have a new boyfriend,
but my ex boyfriend doesn't know it
that yet and I'm terrified that he'll do
what he says. Then suddenly the
thought occurred to me that would,
my life would be much happier without
him and existence and then she said,
I actually did this.
I invited him for dinner and as he
was in the kitchen looking stupid,
peeling the carrots to make salad,
I came up to him laughingly,
gently so that he
wouldn't suspect anything.
I thought about grabbing a knife
quickly and stabbing him in the chest
repeatedly until he was dead.
I actually did the first thing,
but he saw my intentions and ran away.
When asked how close she came to
killing him, she estimated 60%
well
60 I don't think I've ever had a fantasy
that that anatomically specific where I
would see the part of the other person
that I was going to stab or plan it like
that. Well.
Have you ever been blackmailed the way
this woman was being blackmailed? No.
No one has ever said about a six tape
that I've ever know. So you don't know.
It is a fair question to ask.
What are the conditions under which you
or me or any of us could do evil things?
I think they'd have to be extreme in
the extreme. Well, you know how mine?
No. And you know what? This actually
brings us to our first top of the hour.
So let me just to set it up. Robert,
I'm going to give you this piece
of paper here. What is this?
So these are some word pairs. Read these
words that use these words here. Yep.
Nice Day. Fat Neck. Yes. Sad face.
What is it? Soft hair. Yeah. I don't
know what this is. You just wear it.
I want you to commit them to memory
fi. Commit them to memory. You know,
and while you're doing that,
just give me your finger.
I'm going to ask that first little
electro test finger. Let me go hard, Dan.
Just wait a second. Clear air. He
said, give me the paper back. W ready?
Time's up. So I'm just gonna
go into this other room over.
Can you hear me? All right. So I'm gonna
talk to you over this intercom. Okay,
let me give you a test. I'm not
ready for the day. Intention, right?
To the best of your memory.
Which word was mashed with Nice?
Was it? Nice Day. Nice sky. Nice job.
Nice chair. Antifreeze. I
don't want, wait a second.
Just push the button. The
corresponds to the right way to go.
Okay. I'm choosing job wrong.
The answer is day hiring, man. 285
olds have to give you a little,
what did you just, you just
of you're drunk. Obviously.
No need to be an alarm. That was not a
real shock. We were just enacting an old,
very famous experiment that you
might've heard about. It is May,
1962 done by this guy.
An experiment is being conducted in the
elegant interaction laboratory at Yale
University that Stanley Milgram talking
about the experiment in the film in case
you've never heard of, this probably
happened in case you haven't.
Here's what he did. He
recruited a bunch of subjects.
Subjects are 40 males between the ages
of 20 and 50 normal everyday dudes.
The subjects range in occupation
from corporation president,
the good humor man and plumbers and he
ran them through something like what you
and I just did, right.
He would have each subject sit down
at a table right here in front of this
really impressive looking machine. This
machine that had lots of switches on. It
generates electric shocks on your press,
water, the switches all the way down.
The learner gets a shock
and in the other room there was a guy,
then he called the learner who is
supposed to have memorized some words and
every time that guy got a word
wrong, I'm like, you just did. Yup.
Tapping costs, answers. Night.
Volunteer was instructed to shock that
guy with higher and higher voltage.
Now the volunteer couldn't
see the guy who was shocking,
but he could definitely hear him
Milgrom staged the whole thing,
like it was some experiment
about memory and punishment,
but of course it wasn't about
that. I can tell you please.
It was about how far
would these people go,
how many times would they shock that sad
SAP in the next room just because they
were being told Tim guy yelling.
Of course it was an actor
and the shocks weren't real,
but the questions in the air at the
time were very real prosecution.
The attorney general, this was a
moment when human cruelty was on trial.
Quite literally when I stand before
you judges of Israel in this commode,
I used to accuse, I don't
five them and any or maybe d,
I do not stand alone.
The Milgrim actually begins
these experiments the same
year that Adam Eichmann
goes on trial for Nazi war crimes.
That's radio producer Ben Walker.
He'll be our guide for the segment
and in the trial when the prosecutors
essentially ask him how you
came to commit genocide,
he would say over and over again,
it was not my personal affair.
I was just following orders.
I had to do what I was
ordered and it's this defense.
This is basically what Stanley Milgrim
set out to test 185 votes in a lab.
Yale University with a
bunch of regular Americans,
like is that something that the universal
yeah, or just 10 Eichmann thing. Yeah.
He figured maybe 1% of these men would
keep flicking the switches up to the
highest voltage, but
that's not what he found.
65% were willing to shock their fellow
citizens over and over and even past when
they were screaming in pain.
Sounds happened to that man in that
even when they stopped screaming.
Yeah, when they were maybe dead.
You better check in on him, sir. He won't
answer me or nothing. Please continue.
Go on. Twitter.
They continued shocking their corpses.
Wow.
His experiment remains one of the most
famous experiments of the 20th century in
1962 Stanley Milgrim shocked the world
was his study on obedience is still
trotted out to explain everything
from hazing to war crimes.
What is there in human nature to gang
behavior allows an individual to act
inhumanely genocide harshly. It's
like a downloadable from the Internet.
Instant defense for doing wrong, but
if you look at Milgram's work
closely. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like this guy did, oh x,
how's Lim professor of psychology
at the University of Exeter?
Then a different picture will emerge.
Really that story has been told
1,000,001 times for the last 50 years.
We've just got to get,
oh, got to get out for it.
Now what you need to understand about
Alex Haslam is that he hates it when
interviewers only want to
talk about the baseline study.
The one that everybody knows, the
so called baseline, the 65% one,
the one we just talked about. Yeah. So
there's more, there's more too. Yeah.
Because actually he studied between 20
and 40 different variants of this same
paradigm. Stanley Milgram took
electric shock very seriously.
He did this experiment a bunch of times
and a bunch of different ways how all
sorts of different things. He would change
where the shocker and the Shaki Sat.
Yet women participantcy had an
experiment who wasn't a scientist,
but it was a member of the general
public and every scenario produced a
different result. Really? Yup.
Let me, I mean, I'm just, uh,
I've got in front of me, I've just got
the, uh, the data from the Milgrim.
So let me just get that. I mean, so again,
the baseline studies is the one where
65% of volunteers go all the way,
highest dose of electricity, exciting
sex. But in experiment number three,
if they put the Shaki in the
same room with a shocker,
so the shocker can actually see the
person that he's shocking obedience tropes
to about 40% in an
experiment. Number four,
when the teacher has to hold the
learner's hand down on the plate,
in order to him to feel the shock,
they drops to about 30%. Wow.
Experiment 14. If the experiments
are, he is not a scientist,
but is an ordinary man not wearing a
white coat, obedience drops to 20%.
Well, how low can we go? Okay,
here's another one. Experiment 17.
There's you and this to other
participants, both actors.
If those two participants refuse
to go on, like saying like,
I don't want to kill a guy. Boney
10% under those circumstances, go on.
And then the final one,
experiment 15 of course,
normally you just have one experiment
who's giving you these instructions.
But if you put two experimenters in the
room and they start disagreeing with
each other, and this one you get 0%
going on zero z arrive in that condition.
You said Zero Nolan and go right to the
zero at one post. No one not assault.
Exactly 0% well, all right,
I'm starting to feel a little bit
better about my fellow man. One second.
Hey Sh. Okay, where is he?
Am I'm in a closet closet because this
room is echoey and you know there's
nothing like a closet full of clothes
to like help balance that out.
That's true. That's true. All
right, let's keep going. So you see,
it's just in that one experiment that
65% of people are willing to go all the
way, but in all of these
other scenarios, they don't.
And even when they do say yes, even
when they go along with the experiment,
as you can see in the film, they struggle
using the last switch on the board.
Please. I'm not getting no answer.
Please continue. The next word is white.
They have debates with them.
Do you think you should
look in on him? Please?
Fights with the experiments, Huh?
Not Once we've started the experiment of
something happened on mad and attacked
or something like that. The
experiment requires that we continue,
go on and put down that. Don't
the man's health mean anything?
Whether the learner likes it or not.
We might might be better than that.
What's interesting is that
how all of these struggles,
all of them play out the same way.
It's the experimenter
prodding the shockers along.
You're going to keep giving them
what, 450 volts every shot now.
Correct. For me, it's all about
the prods connect words white.
This is what totally
pulled me into this story.
Prods Stanley Milgrim had four scripted
prods that he wrote out for his
experimenters for when the subjects
didn't want to continue. Yup.
The first one was,
please go on and if they
didn't go on, if they resisted,
he experimented with
break out prod number two.
The experiment requires that you continue.
Well, the experiment requires,
I mean I know it does, sir,
but I mean he's up to 195 [inaudible]
and if they still were resisting or
struggling, they'd get prod number three.
It's absolutely essential that you
continue. It's absolutely essential.
It's a little bit more direct. It's
a bit stronger. It's not an order,
not quite, but the fourth prod,
really the, the critical, the critical
false prod is an absolute
order. The fourth prod is
you got to know where the
choice. Do you have no other
choice teacher? You must continue.
That is definitely an order.
Exactly, but every time the experiment
are pulled out, the fourth prod,
and this was confirmed when the
experiment was redone in 2006
total disobedience, Hodel, disobedient.
Anytime the experiment said you must
continue, the shocker would say,
hell no. I've
don't. You have no other choice
teacher. I have a choice.
I'm not going to go ahead with it.
Well, we'll have to discontinue
the experiment. I'm sorry.
Here's another one.
You have no other choice. You
must want to have a choice.
How does it do you all continue up?
We're going to have to discontinue the
experiment, have to, he says cut it out.
After all, he knows what he
can stand. That's my opinion.
That's where I'm going to stand on it.
Well, so the subjects seem willing
to shock another human being,
but as soon as you say it's an order,
they don't do it. Now that's important.
It's very important because if
you ask university undergraduates,
what does the Milgram study show,
they will invariably say something like
they showed that people obey orders.
Okay.
Well actually the one thing that the
study really doesn't show is that people
are, bay ordered is a
pretty big thing. To me.
This is a pretty big thing to
mess, isn't it? Really? See, wait,
if it doesn't show that people
are just obeying orders. Yeah,
and what does it show? Okay. I think
it looks, it's like this. All right,
let's go on to our instructions.
We will begin with this test.
The participants are there in the, in
the study, I've got a, a very plausible,
very credible high status scientists. And
as I say, just scientific institution,
Yale, who is going to do this
powerful piece of science, right?
Your voice toward that
microphone is the room.
So they sit down in the chair thinking,
wow, this is really important.
I'm about to help this quest for
knowledge. I really want to do a good job.
Now as we sort of know in life,
lots of things that we do,
they worthwhile doing and not always easy.
And you find yourself in a situation
where you've got to do something that's
hard, like shocking, an
innocent stranger over and over.
But if you think that's the right thing,
if you think that science is
worth pursuing, you say, okay,
I'll go along with this.
So you're saying you're shocking these
people because they thought it was
worthwhile. Look to participants.
You know, they're not, it's not.
It's not just blind to beaten.
So tell me, so yes sir. No Sir.
Three bags full sir.
They're engaged with the task that
trying to be good participants.
They're trying to do the right thing.
They're not doing something
because they have to.
They're doing it because
they think they ought to.
And that's all the
difference in the world.
Suddenly I'm thinking
this is actually a darker
interpretations. The original,
absolutely darker stay are
doing. And no question about it.
They have the agency. Yep.
And they think it's right.
Although clearly they on some
level, they know it isn't
does this sort of chilling comparison,
which is a speech that Himmler gave to
the SS cmss leaders when they were about
to commit a range of
atrocities. And he said, look,
this is what you're going to do is
of course you don't want to do this.
Of course nobody wants to be killing
other people and we realize this is hard
work.
But what you're doing is for the good of
Germany and this is necessary in order
to advance our noble cause.
Wow.
So then, Hey, wait, I'm almost done
guys. Give me two more minutes.
Two more minutes. Okay.
So in the Milgrim case [inaudible] with
the idea is that people will do bad if
they think it's good,
like the good noble cause.
Well what's the noble cause in
this case? Science, science.
You can see this in the surveys that
the men filled out after the experiments
were over. This was exactly what
was on my mind. If the experiment,
if the experiment had to be
successful, it had to be carried on.
The questionnaires they filled out are
part of the Milgrim archive at Yale.
We're willing to help in a worthwhile
experiment and it's kind of surprising.
A lot of them are really positive even
though they've just been told that they
were duped. Research
in any field is a must,
particularly in this day and age.
Do you think that more studies of this
sort should be carried out? Definitely,
yes.
We as, as onlookers to the study,
we have this kind of Godlike, uh,
sort of vision of like, well of
course what they're doing is wrong,
but if it looks at it
from another perspective,
there's a sense in which
you could celebrate what
they're doing. You're, I mean,
I'm not suggesting one should,
but I'm just saying there is a sense in
which these people are prepared to do
something that's very painful to them
and to someone else because they want to
promote science. Well, you know, you
can see that's a good thing. I mean,
you know
God cause it's like we started with this
experiment that we all see as evidence
of humans, latent capacity for
evil. You tell us actually no,
under some circumstances we don't do
the bad thing we're told to do because
here's another flip. We don't have to
be told. In fact, we hate being told,
but we will do it on our own
if we think it's good. Yeah.
Now you're saying actually
that you could read that,
that very dark fact as being actually
evidence of something quite Nobel. Yeah.
Well if you dressed it up and if
you just had some minor variants,
the paradigm you could presume that
we make, you know, make these up.
These are people who are
incredibly noble. They are,
I mean it's the fact of course that
they're administering pain to a stranger.
That's what's horrifying about it.
But imagine they were
administering paint themselves.
Imagine they were really where I had
to administer shocks themselves or
something. But if they
were prepared to do that,
when I suspect a lot of them
would, um, then we'd say,
these are people who really believe in
Saas and isn't this a good thing that we
have people in our society who are
willing to make sacrifices for the greater
good?
Huh.
So in the end, where do you come down?
Do you leave this experiment in a
light mood or in a dark mood? Uh, I th
I, I overall, I would
say in a powerful mood,
we're close to some really fundamental
truths about human nature. And you know,
my views about human nature is that it
affords infinite potential for lightness
and dark. There's lots and lots of
lessons here and, but one is, I think,
you know, when you are enjoined to
do something for the greater good,
maybe ask yourself the question
what is greater and what is good?
That right there. Slap some
quotations around that.
Yeah. Yeah.
[inaudible]
my thanks to Ben Walker whose podcast
he has a podcast and it's a good one.
It's called too much information.
Yes, it's awesome. Thank you Ben,
and also thank you to Alex Haslam,
professor of psychology at the University
of Exeter. We'll be right back.